yeah but I'm not even sure like people
like like I'm not doing this for people
that are already in the game I'm doing
this for everybody hasn't started yet
got it Micro mom hasn't done a chronic
gravel come around like a visible acting
with clarity hustle my my name is Gary
Tom but I've been telling you how
accountants with equity I'm Tripoli
given a pedigree convening a pleasure my
faculty are putting the works on I'm
Jerry NARS the moving furniture heaven
[Music]
yeah yeah get it off of my couch I tell
the light ivory the function Jessie mr.
no never try over love I better be the
main focus
it's me go enjoy died I'll never lie
god bless kaboom God man
well what it's me you know and I'm time
for you listen to the same exact song
for five hours
that right there real quick you'll see
the image here I just posted to my
Instagram story by the way it's not
follow my Instagram story huge mistake I
feel like that's become an incredibly
important place so I up my snapchat game
to been upping it like everybody asking
me like Instagram story snapchat stories
both both like what happens with
tomorrow snapshot drops some sort of
feature changes everything I'm going to
be scrambling back stay consistent they
consistent as long it's something if
something gets big enough stay
consistent until it's sadder explodes
Twitter and I definitely do a retweet
Club to come up with something cueing
getting a little momentum building
you're not on Twitter listening a lot
there engaging comes from natural don't
get more serious about my Instagram
comments
but uh anyway that exchange you rock so
I have photo
at exchange sparked it like people like
it it's the way you know I 70 right you
know like how to get people started how
does one get started what you saying so
basically I'm going to make a video
that's going to go bonkers anything how
to start how to start I think it's going
to be predicated on getting people to
think that our manifesto whether that's
your mission or where you're at right
now
your truth manifesto you know kind of
the what right i frame it up into like
the what the how is there's only a
certain few ways to communicate in the
world right written word video or audio
so that's the next thing so you got to
be got to talk about your truth or your
mission then you've got to figure out
how you're going to create that
communication only three two pillars
that ren word audio or video that guys
that's how you communicate and then
number three where's the distribution
had going to get it out how to start got
it manifesto or your State of the Union
your truth maybe in a little clip for me
sitting in the actually definitely a
clip from me sitting in that on the
airplane in London where I look like
dark like a like a Star Wars character
things should I hear from everybody with
you know I think the fear of losing
Trump's the excitement of victory so
many people
it could be in a position to be a real
partner of player I'm very empathetic to
the real-life business you're dealing
with well I'm aware that's why I reached
out to you I didn't know what that was
you know they emailed us and we pushed a
meeting that we were supposed to have
because of that and I figured I'd come
to you and like really have that this
combo you know I'm telling you right now
you need to take a step back and give a
real thought you don't really know me
but I think your intuition on me is
right I think I can be a big plus here
instead of a - you need you I'm very
interested in risk especially if I
believe in somebody this is a long game
right I can lose it I can lose the
entire year and win with you in four
years I'm very open I on the other hand
I'm sitting with a lot of extra people
so I have an asset that I can deploy so
I don't know what that means but you
should definitely keep in the back of
your mind you know again I think we're
talking about skill sets and politics so
they don't blend all the time so I'm
very I'm very empathetic but there might
be a way I mean look there might be a
way for the scope to be directly with
you right like ah and small I just uh I
think I think you know I think a lot of
things are going well in my direction
and I could see this really being a huge
win for me if I played this right and
the downside is my all my only downside
is that you know that I'm even smarter
and better than you think
and you feel like I did the right thing
that's not a very big downside how much
do it how much nc are we getting not a
fall in
not gonna come on the phone number
television gray we can use it everywhere
cuz I dunno record you put the pundits
that push agendas with Manchester I
cover the topic what is wanted I'm being
honest these moments Neverland I sit and
watch um passengers but so far now for
the tracks welcome miss Amanda is my
number tag getting started as always the
hardest thing it's just it's so
difficult for so many people crippled
you know the starting point seems to be
the thing that most people can't figure
out and see these different exchangers
I'm starting to figure out of cadence
here I haven't made a detailed post kind
of a step one step two step three it's
really not my style it's a little bit
more from the hip to the heart but I
think I got something I think I really
have this kind of step one step two step
three starts with the manifesto you have
to produce a piece of content and
remember this is not for people who've
already started this is singularly for
people who are sitting and have not
started putting their name or their
business into the world they're crippled
by how do I start how do I get into this
social media game how do I put out my
stuff very simply step one the manifesto
either why you want to start putting out
content or what you're going to start
doing or or where you going or what are
you about the the Y or the what like
what are you about who are you about to
become or or what you want to happen you
know for me legacy of being an
entrepreneur or giving advice or you're
starting this journey to talk about your
barber shop right many held apartment
for months
plan on climates Manny's first video
should have been five months ago like
here we're starting we want to change
the game this is why we did it that's
why we left our shop is what we think we
can do is the beginning either what
you're trying to accomplish or or why
you're trying to do this number two is
there
let me put up the content right there's
only really three core ways in the
current internet to really communicate
to the world the written word
so you blog you post on LinkedIn you
guest blog on different sites you write
by the way you can do the Sun Instagram
you can take a photo and write seven
paragraphs I actually think it's a good
strategy same with Facebook
take a stinking photo like
just and then write something sensitive
19th centure or video what I'm doing
right now
YouTube Facebook video Instagram
one-minute version video is the other
way we communicate a number three audio
the boom of podcast so many people am I
talking screw you up I love it
podcast right all the people that kind
of popped whether Jordan from art of
charm of Pat slim or Lilith house it was
audio that became their kind of a saving
grace and their platform so course you
got to figure out what for why you want
to talk about it and the number two
you've got to figure out where you're
going to deploy your first piece of
manifesto content you have this rant
this mission scheme is this manifesto
and then finally like where where is
this stuff going to show up distribution
that's a big part of the strategy they
cool you figured out what you're going
to talk about I want to save the world
from babysitting mistake so I'm going to
be the biggest sitting expert cool you
figure out how to say it you'll record
it into your voice memo on your phone
and you just kept telling right you
figured it out you ended up being good
in a radio voice and that was where does
it go so it gets very detailed obviously
it's it's written word you look at the
mediums LinkedIn the word presses you
start a blog right or you do it on your
Facebook or you're doing your threa if
it's video you've got YouTube you've got
Facebook you've got Instagram you've got
all these different platforms and then
if it's audio you've got SoundCloud and
and podcasting platform sketcher Google
Voice iTunes you create a podcast in
just Google how do I set up my podcast
how do I get distribute my content but
then you've got to figure out how do
people discover it nowhere right this is
where you go into Roenick lee we're here
again this is where we showed you how to
go into the DF right then before you've
got to figure out how to use some money
and use Facebook ads and target the
people that you're trying to eat or
climbing hustle just literally email is
700 to 1500 different blogs or media
sites and saying if you want to
distribute my content right emailing
Entrepreneur Magazine ink magazine
sitting weekly whatever maybe you got to
get distribution the way you do that is
either time or money money's easy
Facebook add Google Ads
time is hard but if you have no money
it's your only option now they're gonna
cry for you if you want people to know
about your stuff you need to find other
places that have eyeballs or ears and
get it out there so you can ask to be a
guest on other people's blogs or other
people's blogs influence your marketing
you know these are things that you need
to figure out so okay start a nice new
haircut not just come on the problem
number 10 end up giving you one of my
heart and weird ended up in an aside on
the right open its consequence one and
I'm being honest these moments never die
I said to watch a pet but still watch
now for the crack and watch them listen
man just addicted to attention and the
attention not like I need attention
trading attention that's the game people
don't get it
attention the only thing that matters
and then the next thing that matters is
what do you say with that attention
that's it
one-two punch baby in my feminine one
say hey lads I've seen them struggling
survivors where I'm learning in the set
of factors and that's the most insane
- provided you never having yourself a
recall or imagined before arguments over
loafers what is this other dresses will
never settle for messaging clever
speaker progression is over back in the
singlet is mind-boggling so position so
materialistic she can fix on that your
problems and situations in this is a
single Monday doesn't it so the mud is
it if there's a normal conversation for
math in a